♪ ♪
>> Jesse: AFTER GLENN
YOUNGKIN'S SHOCKING WIN IN
VIRGINIA, THE LEFT DOES NOT
ENGAGE IN ANY REFLECTION
WHATSOEVER AND IS INSTEAD
ACCUSING VIRGINIA VOTERS, THE
PEOPLE WHO JUST ELECTED AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR, OF BEING RACIST.
>> AND WHEN HE PUSHES TALKING
POINTS THAT ARE MEANT TO FLIRT
WITH AND STOKE WHITE BLACK LASH,
HE DOES SO IN A CODED WAY WITH
DOG INITIALS ABOUT EDUCATION.
>> THE RACIAL ANIMUS THAT IS
TEAMING WITH THE DOG WHISTLE
MESSAGING.
>> RACIAL LANGUAGE AND DOG
WHISTLES, QUITE FRANKLY.
>> SOME OF IT WAS DOG WHISTLED,
RIGHT?
SOME OF IT WAS DOG WHISTLE
RACISM.
>> HORRIBLE, RACIST, DOG
WHISTLES FROM THE G.O.P.
>> DOG WHISTLING ON EDUCATION.
I THINK ALL OF THIS CRT STUFF IS
TRUMPED UP DOG WHISTLING.
>> WHAT ROSE TO SORT OF A
NATIONAL CONVERSATION WAS THE
DOG WHISTLE.
>> Jesse: NOTICING THEY KEEP
REFERRING TO DOG WHISTLES, BUT
THEY NEVER EVEN SAY WHAT THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
SHELBY STEELE IS THE WRITER OF
THE DOCUMENTARY "WHAT KILLED
MICHAEL BROWN," AND HE JOINS US
WITH A REACTION.
SO SHALL BE, WHY WON'T THEY
DEFINE AND DEFEND EXACTLY WHAT
CRT IS?
>> BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO WAY TO
DO IT.
THEY KNOW THAT IT IS IN
OPPOSITION TO AMERICA'S
COMMITMENT TO RACIAL HARMONY
THAT HAS GONE ON NOW FOR 60-70
YEARS, CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT,
THE CIVIL RIGHTS VICTORIES,
EQUALITY IN THE SENSE, AS
INDIVIDUALS.
ALL OF THAT, THAT CLASSICAL
LIBERALISM, THEY SEE AS
INFRINGING ON THEIR POWER.
IF THEY CAN SUSPEND THAT
LIBERALISM, THEN THEY HAVE THE
POWER TO DICTATE WHAT GOES ON.
YOU SAW TERRY McAULIFFE
TALKING ABOUT ONE SCHOOL THAT
HAD 80% WHITE TEACHERS, WE
NEEDED TO CHANGE THAT, GO
IN, DISREGARD THEIR RIGHTS AND
CUT THAT DOWN TO 50%.
WELL, IT'S THAT KIND OF COLD,
INHUMAN CALCULATION AS A PRETEXT
FOR RACIAL HARMONY THAT IS
EXTREMELY DESTRUCTIVE.
AND THE REACTION TO IT THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THIS CURRENT
ELECTION IS, BY MY LIGHTS, A
WONDERFUL THING.
IT IS A RETURN TO THE CLASSIC
VIEW OF RACIAL HARMONY, BASED ON
OUR CONNECTION AND APPRECIATION
OF EACH OTHER AS INDIVIDUALS,
RATHER THAN STRICTLY MEMBERS OF
A RACE, MEMBERS OF A
NATIONALITY, AND ETHNICITY, AND
SO FORTH.
SO THESE ARE ALL VERY DIVISIVE
WAYS OF THINKING.
>> Jesse: SUCH A BRILLIANT
POINT THAT YOU MADE.
MARTIN LUTHER KING, THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, THAT WAS ALL
ABOUT A COLOR-BLIND SOCIETY.
THAT WAS ABOUT JUDGING PEOPLE
NOT BY THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN,
BUT BY THE CONTENT OF THEIR
CHARACTER, AND THIS IS AGAINST
EVERYTHING THAT THAT WAS ABOUT.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU ARE NOT BORN
EQUAL, PEOPLE ARE BORN RACIST,
EVIL ARE BORN OPPRESSED, AND AS
YOU SAID, THAT FRAMEWORK GIVES
THE LEFT A PRETEXT TO SEIZE
POWER AND THEN REENGINEER
SOCIETY, MOVE PEOPLE UP, PULL
PEOPLE DOWN, REWORK THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM, AND IT JUST TAKES AWAY
WHAT IS IN OUR FOUNDING
DOCUMENT, THAT ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS BURDENSOME AS FAR AS
THEIR CONCERNS.
THEY TRULY ARE OFFENDED BY THAT,
BY THIS IDEA THAT WE SHOULD BE
TREATED AS INDIVIDUALS.
THEY HAVE, OVER THE LAST --
SINCE THE '60s, GAINED
ENORMOUS POWER, THE POWER OF THE
AMERICAN LAUGHTER REALLY IS
GROUNDED IN RACE.
IN THE IDEA OF AMERICA AS A
VICTIMIZING, OPPRESSIVE NATION,
AND THAT THEY THEN CAST
THEMSELVES AS OUR REDEEMER IS.
THEY ARE GOING TO LIFT US OUT OF
THIS SHAME, AND AS SUCH, THEY
NEED THE POWER TO SOCIALLY
ENGINEER WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT
WHETHER THEY ARE BEING CIVILIZED
OR NOT.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE PREYING ON
WHITE GUILT, AND I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN